okay up to now we've talked about
estimating regression functions for
quantitative response
and and we've seen how to do model
selection there now we're going to move
to classification problems
and here we've got a different kind of
response variable it's what we call a
qualitative variable for example email
is is one of two classes spam or ham
ham being the good email
and if we classify in digits it's one of
the classes zero one through up to nine
and it so it's a slightly different
problem and our goals are slightly
different as well
here our goals are to build a classifier
which we might call c of x
that assigns a class label from our set
c
to a
future unlabeled observation x where h
is x is the feature vector
we'd also like to assess the uncertainty
in each classification
and we'd also like to understand the
roles of the different predictors
amongst the x's in in producing that
classifier
and so we're going to see how how we do
that
in in the next number of slides
okay
to try and parallel our development for
the quantitative response
i've made up a little simulation example
and we've got one x
one y the y takes on two values in this
example the values are just coded as
zero and one
and we've got a big sample of of these
wires from a population
so here each little vertical bar here
indicates
an a
an occurrence of a zero
the orange the orange vertical bars as a
function of the x's
and at the at the top we've got where
the the ones occurred
okay
so this scatter plot's much harder to
read you can't really see what's going
on
and there's a black curve drawn in the
figure
and the black curve was what actually
generated the data
the black curve is actually showing us
the probability of a 1 in the model that
i used to generate the data
and
you know so so
up in this region over here the hype the
high values of x there's a higher
probability of a one
it's close to
close ninety percent of getting a one
and so of course we see more
blue ones there than we see zeros down
there
and even though it's hard to see there's
a higher density
of
zeros in this region over here where the
probability is
is 0.4 of being a one
versus
versus a zero it's 0.6 okay
so
we want to talk about what is an ideal
classifier c of x
okay so let's define these probabilities
that i was talking about
and we'll call p sub k of x
this quantity over here
that's a conditional probability
that y is k given x equals x
in this case we've we're just looking at
probability
of 1 in the plot we've just shown the
probability
that y is 1 there's only two classes but
in general there'll be say capital k
classes
and they'll be capital k of these
conditional probabilities
now
in classification problems those
conditional probabilities
completely capture the distribution the
conditional distribution of y given x
okay
and it turns out that those also deliver
the ideal classifier
we call the bayes optimal classifier
the classifier that classifies to the
class for which the conditional
probability
for that element of the class is is
largest
it makes sense you go to any point
so here we've gone to 0.5
in in the x space
and you look above it
and you see that
there's
about 80 percent probability of a one
and twenty percent probability of a zero
and now we're going to say well if you
were to classify to one class at that
point which class would you classify to
well you're going to classify to the
majority class
okay and that's called the bayes optimal
classifier
here's the same example
except now we've only got a handful of
points we've got 100 points
having one one of the two class labels
the story is the same as before
we can't compute the conditional
probabilities exactly say at the point
five because in this case we may have
one we've got one one at at five and and
no zeros
so we send out a neighborhood say and
gather ten percent of the of the data
points and then estimate the conditional
probabilities by the proportions
in this case of ones and zeros in the
neighborhood
and
those are indicated by these little
bars here these are meant to represent
the probabilities or proportions
at this point five and again there's a
higher proportion of ones here than
zeros forgot to say that in the previous
slide that's the same quantity over here
that's indicating the probabilities of
the ones and the zeros this is exact in
the population
and year it is estimated with the
nearest neighbor average
so here we've done the nearest neighbor
classifier classifying in one dimension
where we can draw a nice picture but of
course this works in multiple dimensions
as well just like it did for regression
so suppose we for example have two x's
and they placed in the
they lie in the floor
and we
have a target point
say this point over here
and we want to classify a new
observation who falls at this point well
we can spread out a little say circular
neighborhood and gather a bunch of
observations who fall in this
neighborhood and we can count how many
in class 1 how many in class 2 and
assign to the majority class and of
course this can be generalized to
multiple dimensions
then all the problems we had with
nearest neighbors
for regression the cursor dimensionality
when the number of dimensions get large
also happens here in order to gather
enough points when the dimensions really
high we have to
send out a bigger and bigger sphere to
capture the points
and and things start to break down
because it's not not local anymore
so some details
typically we'll measure the performance
of the classifier using what we call the
misclassification error rate
and here it's written on the test data
set the error is just the average
mistake number of mistakes we make
okay
so it's the average number of times that
the classification so c hat at a point x
i is not equal to the class label why i
averaged over a test set
just the number of mistakes
so that's when we count a mistake um
mistaking a one for a zero and a zero
for a one is as equal
the other ways of classifying error
where you can you can
have a cost which gives higher cost to
some mistakes than others but we won't
go that into that here
so that bayes classifier
the one that used the true probabilities
to decide on the classification rule
is the one that makes the least mistakes
in the population
and that makes sense if you if you look
at our
population example over here by
classifying to one over here
we're going to make mistakes on on about
20 percent of the population of the
conditional population at this value of
x but we'll get it correct 80 percent of
the time
and so that's why it's obvious we want
to classify to the largest class we'll
make the fewest mistakes
later on in the course we're going to
talk about support vector machines and
they build structured models for the
classifier c of x
we also build structured models for
representing the probabilities
themselves and and there we'll discuss
methods like logistic regression and
generalized additive models
the high dimensional problem is
worse for
for modeling the probabilities than it
is for actually building the classifier
for the classifier you just have to
the classifier just has to be accurate
with regard to which of the
probabilities is largest whereas if
we're really interested in the
probabilities themselves we're going to
be measuring them on a much finer scale
okay we'll end up with
a two-dimensional example of nearest
neighbors
so here's a this is that represents the
truth
we've got an x1 and x2
and we've got it points from some
population
and the purple dotted line is what's
called the bayes decision boundary since
we know the truth here we know what the
true probabilities are
everywhere in this domain and i sort of
indicated all the points in the domain
by the little dots in in the in the
figure
and so if you classify according to the
true probabilities
all the points all the region colored
orange would be classified as the one
class
and all the region colored blue would be
classified as the as the blue cast
and the dotted lines called the decision
boundary and so that's a contour of the
place where in this case they're two
classes it's a contour of where the
probabilities are equal for the two
classes so it's an undecided region it's
called the decision boundary
okay so
we can do nearest neighbor averaging in
two dimensions
so of course what we do here
is at any given point when we want to
classify
let's say we pick this point over here
we'll spread out a little neighborhood
in this case until we find the 10
closest points to the target point
and we'll estimate the probability at
this center point here by the proportion
of blues versus oranges and you do that
at every point
and if you use those as the
probabilities you get this somewhat
wiggly black curve
as the estimated decision boundary
and you can see it's it's actually apart
from the somewhat ugly wiggliness
it gets reasonably close to the true
decision boundary which is the again the
purple dashed line
a curve
okay in the last slide we used k equals
10
we can use other values of t of k k
equals 1 is a popular choice this is
called the nearest neighbor classifier
and we take literally for each at each
target point we find the closest point
amongst the training data and classified
to its class
okay so for example if we took a point
over here
which is the closest training point well
this is it over here it's a blue so we'd
classify this as blue
right when you're in the sea of blues of
course they always the nearest point is
always another blue and so you'd always
classify as blue
it's what's interesting is as you get
close to to some of the the orange
points
and what this gives you you can see that
the boundary here is
is a piecewise linear boundary of course
the probabilities we estimate is just
one and zero because there's only one
point to average so there's no real
probabilities but if you think about the
decision boundary it's a piecewise
linear decision boundary
and it's gotten by looking at the
the bisector of the of the the line
joining
separating each pair of points when they
have different colors
so you get this very
ragged
decision boundary you also get little
islands so for example there's a blue
point in the sea of oranges here so
there's a little piecewise linear
boundary around that blue point
those are the points
the the points that are closest to that
blue point closer to the blue point than
the oranges
again we see the true boundary
or the best bayes decision boundary is
purple
this nearest neighbor average
kind of approximates it in a noisy way
on the other end you can make k really
large
um here we've made k a hundred
and
the neighborhood's really large it's
it's essentially there's 200 points here
so it's taking half the points to be in
any given neighborhood
right so let's suppose
our test point was over here
you know we'd be sending out quite a big
circle
gathering 100 points
getting the proportion of blues a
proportion of oranges and then making
the boundary so as k gets bigger this
boundary starts smoothing out and and
getting less interesting in this case
it's almost like a linear boundary over
here and doesn't pick up the nuances of
the of the decision boundary
whereas if with k equals 10 it seemed
like a pretty good choice and it kind
kind of approximates that this is the
decision boundary pretty well
okay so the choice of k is a is a tuning
parameter and that needs to be selected
and here we show what happens as you
vary k
first on the training data and then on
the test data so on the training data
k tends to just keep on decreasing it's
not actually monotone because we've
actually indexed this as 1 over k
because
as k as 1 over k gets
big
let's see k large means we get high bias
so 1 over k is small so this is the low
complexity region this is the high
complexity region
now you notice that the training error
for one nearest neighbors which is right
down at the the end here
whenever k is one is zero
well if you think about it that's what
it's got to be
if you think about what training error
is for the test error it's actually
started increasing again
this horizontal dotted line is is is the
bayes error which is
you can't do better than the bayes error
in theory
of course this is a finite test data set
but it doesn't it actually just touches
on the bayes error it starts decreasing
and then at some point it levels off and
then starts increasing again
so if we had a validation set available
that's what we'd use to determine k
so that's our nearest neighbor
classification very powerful tool
um it said that about one-third of
classification problems the best two
will be
nearest labor classification
on the handwritten zip code problem the
classifying handwritten digits nearest
neighbor classifiers do about as well as
any any other method tried
so it's a powerful technique to have in
the in the tool bag and it's one of the
techniques that we'll use for
classification but in the rest of the
course we'll cover other techniques as
well
in particular there's support vector
machines
various forms of logistic regression and
linear discriminant analysis